can you move a bit more forward now no  not that way now the camera can't see  what i'm about no it's not me  all right come back why i do this this  is to promote your movie  very nice no no please don't do that  some silly billy put green pepper on  floors no that's meant to be there  killing some of the virus you can't see  the virus no it's still there  point up yeah but look at the cameras  you're doing  can you move a bit more forward now no  not that way now the camera can't see  what my name is no it's not me  all right come back why i do this this  is to promote your movie  very nice no please don't do that  some silly billy put green pepper on  floors no that's meant to be there  killing some of the virus you can't see  the virus no it's still there  point up yeah but look at the cameras  you're doing  [Music]  you